PLATFORM, AND THE PEOPLE CHOSE
TRUMP, AND THAT’S THE "ANGLE" ."
MEANWHILE, LET’S SHED SOME LIGHT
ON THE DEMOCRATS GLARING
HYPOCRISY IN ACCUSING
REPUBLICANS OF UNDERMINING THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION, AS I JUST
ALLUDED TO.
NOW, YOU RECALL DEMOCRATS DID
EVERYTHING THEY COULD TO
UNDERMINE KEN STARR’S WHITEWATER
INVESTIGATION INTO MISDEEDS BY
PRESIDENT CLINTON, AND TO
COMPARE WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING NOW WITH WHAT THEY SAID
BACK THEN.
>> THERE IS A GROWING CONCERN, I
CAN TELL YOU, AND THE SENATE, IN
THE SENSE THAT MR. STARR IS NOW
OPERATING OUT OF ANY SENSE OF
REASONABLE BEHAVIOR.
>> WE GET A POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED PROSECUTOR WHO IS
ALLIED WITH THE RIGHT WING OF
OPPONENTS OF MY HUSBAND WHO HAS
LITERALLY SPENT FOUR YEARS
LOOKING AT EVERY PHONE
BILL -- LOOKING AT EVERY TELEPHE
CALL WE’VE MADE, EVERY CHECK
WITH EVER WRITTEN.
>> THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO, ON
MANY ISSUES, IS BASICALLY BEYOND
SHAME AT THIS POINT.
SO ANY SENSE OF FAIRNESS OR
THOROUGHNESS FOR THE SAKE OF THE
INVESTIGATION, I THINK, IS
QUESTIONABLE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> HE IS TRYING TO DISTRACT
ATTENTION FROM THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION AND TO DISCREDIT
WHATEVER MUELLER SAYS IN THE
END.
>> Laura: HA!
I LOVE THAT.
LET’S GO TO THE MAN WHO WAS IN
THE EYE OF THE STORM BACK THEN.
FORMER INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
KEN STARR JOINS US, AND
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS IN MIAMI.
GUYS, BEFORE WE GET INTO THE
RUSSIA PROBE, I NEED TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS UPROAR OVER THE
STAFF SECRETARY ROB PORTER.
HE IS NOW ACCUSED BY A COUPLE OF
EX-WIVES OF INDECENT BEHAVIOR,
AND THIS WAS AN ABSOLUTE
FIRESTORM IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING ROOM TODAY.
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ, YOUR
REACTION TO THE PRETTY QUICK
TAKEDOWN OF ROB PORTER?
>> WELL, I WANT TO MAKE A
LEGITIMATE POINT.
I THINK EVERYBODY WHO IS ACCUSED
BY THE #MadeTo PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE THEIR CASE, TO PRESENT
THEIR ARGUMENT.
IT USED TO BE THAT IT WAS A SHE
SAID-HE SAID DISPUTE, NOW IT IS
A SHE SAID-YOU CAN’T EVEN
RESPOND DISPUTE.
BOTH SIDES HAVE TO BE HEARD.
A PROCESS HAS TO BE PUT IN
PLACE, WHETHER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND CONGRESS,
ANYWHERE ELSE, WHETHER IT IS A
REPUBLICAN, LIKE IN THIS CASE,
OR A DEMOCRAT LIKE AL FRANKEN,
THERE HAS TO BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR BOTH SIDES TO PRESENT
EVIDENCE AND THERE HAS TO BE A
FAIR PROCESS.
SOMETIMES IT IS OBVIOUS, IT
SOMETIMES IT’S CLEAR, BUT EVEN
IN THE BILL COSBY CASE, WHERE IT
SEEMS SO OBVIOUS TO EVERYBODY,
THE JURY CAME BACK WITH A HUNG
JURY.
SO WE NEED TO HAVE A PROCESS.
WE CAN’T SUSPEND DUE PROCESS
JUST BECAUSE THERE IS A MOVEMENT
AFOOT THAT IS MAKING SOME VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT POINTS.
BUT WE NEED YOU PROCESS.
>> Laura: JUDGE STARR, NOW THE
MOVE SEEMS TO BE TO TAKE DOWN
KELLY BECAUSE KELLY HAS WORKED
SIDE-BY-SIDE BY HIM, EVEN AS ONE
OF HIS EX-WIVES SAID, I DON’T
WANT HIM TO LOSE HIS POSITION IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE IS INCREDIBLY SMART,
INCREDIBLY DEDICATED TO HIS JOB,
BUT I PERSONALLY HAD -- THEY HAD
A BAD RELATIONSHIP, ACCORDING TO
HER.
BUT NOW THEY ARE SAYING KELLY
HAS GOT TO GO BECAUSE KELLY
ACTUALLY STOOD UP FOR HIS
INTEGRITY BECAUSE, AS
ALAN DERSHOWITZ SAID, THESE WERE
ACCUSATIONS, HAVEN’T SEEN A
PHOTO OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT I
GUESS.
>> WRIGHT, GENERAL KELLY, I
THINK, WAS WAITING FOR THE
EVIDENCE, AND WHEN THE EVIDENCE
CAME IN, FROM WHAT WE KNOW, HE
RESPONDED, AND HE RESPONDED
DECISIVELY, WHICH IS WHAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT OF A GOOD MILITARY
MAN.
LET ME ADD TO WHAT ALAN SAID,
AND I AGREE TO WHAT WE SAID, THE
HISTORY OF LIBERTY IN THE
UNITED STATES IS LARGELY THE
HISTORY OF PROCEDURE.
THROW AWAY PROCEDURE, THROWAWAY
DUE PROCESS, AND HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT KIND OF STATE.
YOU DO NOT HAVE A RULE OF LAW
SYSTEM.
IT IS PRECIOUS, AND SO RUSHES TO
JUDGE ARE TO BE AVOIDED.
LET’S GET THE EVIDENCE, EVALUATE
THE EVIDENCE.
I THINK, FROM WHAT WE KNOW,
THAT’S WHAT GENERAL KELLY WAS
DOING.
>> Laura: YEAH.
LET’S MOVE ON FROM THAT TO WHAT
IS HAPPENING TODAY, TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING TODAY IN THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ, WE NOW
KNOW THAT THE CLINTONS PAID FOR
THAT DOSSIER.
IT LOOKS LIKE NOW SIDNEY
BLUMENTHAL WAS INVOLVED, AND OLD
CLINTON HAND, JUDGE STARR KNOWS
ABOUT HIM VERY WELL, FUNNELING
INFORMATION TO CHRISTOPHER
STEELE AS WELL.
SOME OF IT LOOKS LIKE IT ENDED
UP IN THAT DOSSIER, OR A SECOND
DOSSIER THAT ENDS UP FUNNELING
AND IN SOME WAY, SHAPE, OR FORM
TO THAT PFIZER JUDGE.
AND
YET DEMOCRATS WILL SAY, WELL,
THAT IS NOT -- THE SEARCH
WARRANT TO FOLLOW CARTER PAGE
WAS NOT ONLY BASED IN PART ON
THAT.MY DOSSIER.
SO YOU CAN THROW THE BABY OUT
WITH THE BATHWATER.
>> WELL, WE DON’T KNOW WHAT THE
FISA COURT DECIDED, HOW MUCH
WEIGHT THEY GAVE ANYTHING.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW MUCH WEIGHT
WAS GIVEN BY THE FISA COURT TO
ANYTHING.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS, PEOPLE WHO
FOLLOW AN APPLICATION X
PARTAKE HAVE A SPECIAL
OBLIGATION
AND TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE
RELYING ON SOMETHING, AND THEY
KNOW THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
HIS CREDIBILITY BECAUSE OF THE
SOURCE.
THEY HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
PRESENTED FULL      FULSOMELY TE
COURT.
THAT IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
YOU NEED TO PRESENT -- YOU NEED
TO ACT AS IF THE DEFENSE IS
PRESENTING THEIR SIDE.
YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
PRESENT BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE.
AGAIN, AS KEN SAID, IT IS ALL
ABOUT PROCESS.
PROCESS IS THE WAY WE ACHIEVE
PROCESS, AND I THINK THERE ARE
PROBLEMS WITH THE PROCESS.
ISSUE, BUT AT THE MOMENT, I
THINK THERE WAS A BREAKDOWN OF
PROCESS.
>> Laura: JUDGE STARR, AS A
FORMER APPELLATE COURT JUDGE,
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS FISA JUDGE,
WE DON’T KNOW WHO IT IS.
I GUESS THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
JUDGES INVOLVED, IF A MATERIAL
FACT HAD BEEN WITHHELD IN THAT
APPLICATION TO SPY ON AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN AND A MATERIAL
FACT IS, THE OPPOSITION
CANDIDATE PAID FOR THE DOSSIER
AMONG OTHER THINGS, IS THERE ANY
RECOURSE FOR THE JUDGE AT THIS
POINT?
IS THERE SANCTIONS THAT CAN BE
FILED AGAINST CERTAIN JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ATTORNEYS?
WE HAD A GUEST ON THE OTHER
NIGHT WHO SAID HE THOUGHT THERE
COULD BE ETHICAL ISSUES FOR THE
FBI AND MAYBE EVEN CRIMINAL
CHARGES IF, INDEED, THERE WAS A
CONSPIRACY TO KEEP THIS
INFORMATION.
>> IS SERIOUS.
LET’S NOT RUSH TO JUDGMENT.
LET’S BE CONSISTENT AND SAY, WE
NEED TO KNOW HOW THAT PFIZER
APPLICATION FOR THE RENEWAL WAS.
WHO PREPARED IT, WHAT DID THEY
KNOW, WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT.
I THINK THIS IS VERY SERIOUS FOR
THE REASONS THAT ALAN STATED.
ANOTHER REASON, THE FISA REGIME
WAS DESIGNED TO PRODUCE A
JUDICIAL CHECK ON WHAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE AN UNTRAMMELED
EXECUTIVE EXCESS OF POTENTIAL
ABUSES.
AND SO THERE IS A VERY
SPECIAL -- CALL IT A FIDUCIARY
RELATIONSHIP THAT I THINK IT’S
VERY DEEP, PROBABLY AS DEEP AS
IT GETS.
THERE ALWAYS SHOULD BE HONESTY
AND TRANSPARENCY, BUT IT IS ALL
THE MORE SENSITIVE WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE POWER OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO SPY ON
AMERICANS --
>> Laura: GO BACK AND READ
YOUR EMAILS.
THERE IS ONE MORE SOUND BITE I
WANT TO PLAY FOR YOUR      YOU .
THIS IS ERIC HOLDER, FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL, SPEAKING OUT
TODAY.
LET’S WATCH.
>> IF ONE LOOKS AT THE DISMISSAL
OF JAMES COMEY AND THE REASONS
BY THE PRESIDENT TOLD LESTER
HOLT HE DID THAT, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE PRESIDENT’S ATTEMPTS TO GET
PEOPLE WHO WERE HEADS OF THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO GET
INVOLVED IN THIS MATTER, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT’S AS --  ,
I THINK YOU TECHNICALLY HAVE A
CASE OF OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
>> Laura: PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ, YOUR REACTION TO
THAT VERY QUICKLY?
>> WELL, I THINK HE’S WRONG.
PRESIDENT GEORGE BUSH THE FIRST
DID PRACTICALLY THE SAME THING
WHEN IT CAME TO THE IRAN
CONTRACT.
HE PARDONED CASPAR WEINBERGER
AND A HANDFUL OF OTHER
WITNESSES, NOBODY SUGGESTED
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
A PRESIDENT CAN’T OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE, IN MY VIEW, IF YOU
SIMPLY EXERCISE HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY.
HE HAS TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
PERJURY, DESTROYED EVIDENCE, PAY
HUSH MONEY THE WAY NIXON DID.
>> Laura: ERIC HOLDER HAS AN
INTERESTING WAY OF LOOKING AT
THESE FACTS.
BUT I KNEW DERSH WOULD GET IT
RIGHT AS USUAL.
THE DYNAMIC DUO, FANTASTIC.